[Music]
it was urgent to first establish a
diagnosis a diagnosis on the threats
and attacks against European democracies
attacks which are
fomented by hostile foreign states
these attacks which they  are of
various kinds it is cyber
attacks against our institutions it is
disinformation campaigns on
platforms it is the capture of
elites it is also the financing of
political parties and political campaigns
that aim to undermine our
institutions by  abroad
better than thanks to the voice of the
ning commission and the european parliament
have made an extraordinary it will pass
in timid significant rise sounded
the hallali
we boobed vehicles report and nelly
samurai zynga refining the other
sporting to finish towards problem at the
police
the cowboys regulator
is filled
[Music]
habitat wait-and-see attitude and addictions
various occasions and an eponymous tale
minty multeau part col  lard there are
modifications particularly the
mobile guards and through what is
the activities by grace and the nostra
commission
deliberates the national front displays a
positioning to the russians for a long time
since the break-up of the ussr but at the
time of these  loans of its funding,
lobbying has intensified
quite spectacularly
, which is concretely illustrated by
the defense of Russian interests
through public declarations,
propaganda videos of votes, for
example, that the association agreement with
the  ukraine where or against
the kremlin anti union propaganda report
then one can always attempt to
discuss taiwan tibet
hong kong uighurs situation of
migrant workers but only in
communist party terms and the
best is  not to talk about it at all
another problem came from
such a phenomenon still in European life
said
we find legs all
pol groups  and of all the countries which,
once their career is over but just two
seconds later, will sign fabulous contracts
with companies which
are the armed wing of regimes hostile to
our principles and our interests and therefore
we will have to put an end to this
great betrayal of the elites
harmonize electoral laws and
prohibit foreign financing
for political parties and formations
track down the citizens and shell
companies investing massively
in our cyber security and
sanction much more harshly the
states which coordinate the attacks against
our institutions impose
responsibilities to digital platforms
let's build a lasting system to protect the European information space let's do it quickly we have to do
more American public opinion
continues
to do
well my father you're not bringing
interest rates continue to the farce that
the institution  missed and single i
started effective nationalism at
souvi  take part in the lot of the
term interference under pain of the contrast give
shape to Indians of apart bichot jet
which has the authority match happy that we
can continue our work to
defend a European democracy in
particular in the perspective of the
elections of  2000 24 under seal
interference is an
ephemeral phenomenon it will be a continuous low-
intensity war and it was important
not for parliament to say so it's
good we took care of it and then the
subject disappears in the various
committees we have to manage to
keep our attention focused on
this problem and that we ensure
that citizens none
go to vote in 2024 in
conditions of serenity of security
ken levine des spect art inc democracy
now
sousse  tap des spectra and a new show
[Music]
[Applause]